you think it's become more popular for  people who leave their jobs when they're  unhappy in the 80s people used to earn  big bucks but they're not happy do you  think there is a correlation to where we  are now every generation is more  thoughtful than the prior one because  you have the luxury of the data we got  to watch the people who grew up in the  60s and 70s and you got to watch the  people who grew up in the 80s 90s and  2000s and there's more options there's  more information i lived my entire  childhood up until i was 19 years old  without the internet in the 80s finding  a new job was looking in the classifieds  in a newspaper recruiters couldn't email  you or hit you up on linkedin and with  more options comes better decisions  people are becoming more thoughtful when  i was growing up to your point make as  much money as possible so you can get a  house and a car and a vacation and now  people are more minimalists value other  things and i think it's a beautiful  thing